well,
how are you, cristian cásseres greets you with
his new disney news program in
spanish the gender police are
investigating an apparent bear crash at a
busy intersection in the valley the
accident happened on eastern
and saint rose streets early
on monday morning both  vehicles
started and at the time of this
report the police had not revealed any
further details and I am telling you that the metropolitan police are
still looking for the
suspect in shooting seven
people everything happened in the
temporary housing complex i follow
sweetzer houses on flamingos and mermen parkway streets
Investigators say that apparently the
altercation began after a dispute between
neighbors and a fire broke out in the
La Bonita supermarket near the
streets and ser or order. Nobody was
injured.
Fortunately, now the
store manager has scheduled a meeting with
the health department.  from
clark county to assess all damages and
as of monday can  Candidates looking to
run for this
year's elections may register depending on
the electoral department they are
transmitting applications during their
normal hours of service for more
information you can visit our
dotcom page in the Spanish section and
the cold temperatures continue in the
valley we also start the week with
strong winds here we present the
forecast for the week we will have
winds of 30 miles per hour this
will keep the day cool despite being
a sunny day temperatures
only in the 50s I am cristian
cásseres with your iris informative forecast
not in Spanish good day
[Music]